lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
revisar varios ejemplos que nos ayudan a
comprender mejor lo que significa sumar
o restar un número positivo o negativo y
conforme vayamos viendo los ejemplos yo
los invito a que vayan pasando el vídeo
cada vez para tratar de resolverlo por
su cuenta y después ver cómo podemos
resolverlo juntos
comencemos si yo les dijera que menos 1
es igual a 7 menos un espacio en blanco
quién número debería ir en este espacio
en blanco que el número positivo o
negativo o incluso podría ser 0 al
colocarlo aquí nos daría esta igualdad
vamos a dibujar una recta numérica acá y
ahora veamos qué es lo que está
sucediendo queremos llegar a menos 1
estamos comenzando en 7 aquí está el 7
comenzamos en el 7 que le tenemos que
quitar al 7 para poder llegar a este
menos 1 de acá pues tenemos que movernos
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 lugares hacia la
izquierda lo que acabamos de hacer es
restar 8 del 7 para llegar al menos 1
así que necesitamos restar pues
necesitamos restar 8 hagamos otro
ejemplo ahora nos dicen que menos diez
más algo en blanco debe ser igual a
menos 5 que es lo que debe ir en ese
espacio en blanco para que esto se
cumpla
pongamos otra recta numérica veamos
vamos a comenzar en menos 10 aquí
tenemos el menos diez y tenemos que
agregarle algo a esto para llegar al
menos 5 y recordemos que el menos cinco
es este de aquí
sumar significa que vamos a agregar algo
hacia la derecha de la recta numérica
para sumar un número positivo y
efectivamente aquí en la recta numérica
vemos que tenemos que movernos hacia la
derecha para llegar de el menos 10 al
menos 5 así que vamos a sumar un número
positivo si sumáramos un número negativo
tendríamos que movernos más hacia la
izquierda cuánto es lo que vamos a sumar
vamos a ver 1 2 3 4 5 así que sumamos 5
5 positivo menos 10 más 5 es igual a
menos 5 podemos decir que nos volvimos 5
veces menos negativos hagamos otro
ejemplo ahora nos dicen que 4 es igual a
menos 2 más un espacio en blanco igual
que las otras ocasiones vamos a tomar
nuestra recta numérica para visualizar
qué es lo que tenemos que hacer
una forma de verlo es que nuestra meta
nuestro objetivo es llegar al 4 positivo
y aquí tenemos 1 2 3 4 aquí está nuestra
meta y comenzamos en menos 2 y decimos
que 4 es lo mismo que menos 2 que está
aquí más cierta cantidad tenemos que
movernos hacia la derecha así que vamos
a sumar una cantidad positiva y nos
vamos a mover 1 2 3 4 5 6 lugares a la
derecha
así que sumamos 6 menos 2 + 6 es igual a
esto es fascinante hagamos otro
ejercicio bueno ahora nos dicen que
vamos a tener 6 más un espacio en blanco
y todo esto es igual a menos 8
nuevamente traten de pausa del vídeo e
intenten resolverlo por su cuenta
bueno ponemos nuestra recta numérica acá
una forma de pensar en ello es comienzo
en el 66 positivo que está aquí y tengo
que agregar algo para llegar a menos 8 y
este menos 8 está aquí menos 5 6 7 menos
8 aquí está pero que tengo que hacer
para ir de este 6 positivo a este 8
negativo pues claramente tengo que
moverme hacia la izquierda cuanto me
tengo que mover a la izquierda sobre la
recta numérica vamos a ver
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 así que
tiene un nuevo 14 lugares a la izquierda
realmente estoy restando 14 y si está
escrito que 6 más algo es igual a menos
8 pues la respuesta va a ser 6 más menos
14 y aquí nuestra expresión dijera 6
menos algo pues solamente escribiríamos
el 14 pero tenemos un más no un menos
así que esto es 6 más menos 14 ó 14
negativo